i would rather have a conversation i
would rather spend time
you know acquiring information listening
to interesting podcasts and then talk
about what i've been listening to and
reading hi there steve kaufman here and
today i want to talk about task-based
language learning
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe
click on the bell for notifications uh
if you follow me on a podcast service uh
please leave review i do appreciate it
so task based language learning the
really the reason i raised this subject
is because i realized just how important
it is in language learning to have
specific tasks
i noticed this that that if i assign
myself a task
or if i feel an obligation to do
something or if someone assigns a task
to me then i'm likely to do it simply
because it's it's easy to have a task if
my wife says you know
chop these vegetables okay i chop the
vegetables it helps it's you don't have
to kind of think what should i be doing
now you have a task
and the same with language learning so
first thing in the morning uh typically
i'll listen to a podcast
and then i'll try and grab the url if
it's on youtube and somehow get an mp3
file so that i can get it transcribed
so now i've got this task that's
developing i'm listening to this podcast
i'm i've got the transcript i'm studying
a transcript on link without even having
to think about it i have this task that
i have to do
if my tutor were to assign me a task
here are three lessons i want you to
read them i want you to say words and
phrases or
when we're on our 90-day challenge i'm
trying to keep up to a certain level in
terms of links created or words known
these are very specific
things over and above my
general interest in the language
specific tasks that help get me going
and like so much in like life it's
important to get going it's important to
do something if you do something it
leads to other things so tasks i think
are very important to keep us you know
going forward in our language learning
activities
but when you say task based language
learning if you google for it you'll
find a different definition
and that task based language instruction
is a method of language instruction
where as i understand it
the learner is asked to perform a task
in the language
not to worry about grammar structures or
vocabulary and to incorporate you know
hand gestures or whatever
in order to accomplish a task in the
language
now i don't know whether this is an
effective way of teaching the language
to me it's a little artificial
it's a bit like this role-playing thing
which i also don't particularly like i
would rather have a conversation i would
rather spend time
you know acquiring information listening
to interesting podcasts and then talk
about what i've been listening to and
reading
and sort of gradually see my vocabulary
increase my comprehension level increase
i'm not that interested in gay in
engaging in these artificial activities
the uh
one example of the application of this
task based language instruction
and of course in the field of language
instruction there are all kinds of
you know the latest
you know fad
as i see it
i
i'm with crash and i think language
instruction comes down to comprehensible
compelling input massive listening and
reading allowing the brain to get used
to the language and everything else
these kind of refinements are which are
either
interesting or not very interesting but
maybe not all that necessary one
application is in canada we have a thing
called the 12 language benchmarks which
is again
yet another way of grading people's
language skills we have toefl and toeic
and ielts and cambridge so there's
another one canadian language benchmarks
there are 12 levels
and each level tries to describe
in terms of you know
listening comprehension reading
comprehension speaking and writing you
know what the person's level is well
level one
that can't do much so it's just
you know can hardly say anything okay
that's level one level two
can hardly say anything but can say a
little more than level one in other
words all of the detailed description of
what this person is able to do is
relatively meaningless to me
the person is gradually getting better
hopefully and there are no clear
you know
demarcation lines between level 3 and
level four and five that's why beginner
intermediate and advanced is pretty good
because it's simple it's a fluid thing
it's not like there are steps like this
that we go through and we may be
progressing more quickly in
comprehension not as quickly in speaking
or in writing or we may not even bother
with writing and so trying to say that
at each you know benchmark level here is
a clear definition of what this person
can do now the reason for this is
that for this canadian language
benchmark system they they hope that um
immigrants for example can demonstrate
the ability to perform
tasks related to being a clerk uh you
know in a supermarket or a receptionist
at a hotel
jobs that are considered to be you know
less demanding when it comes to language
and maybe
you know jobs that immigrants could
easily fill once they achieve that level
now of course here again
uh i have uh
met many checkout clerks at supermarkets
many of whom are immigrants they all
speak
quite well i mean the ones that are good
at it they can actually entertain
conversations on different subjects i i
don't think
it's that useful to try to just train
yourself on the limited number of words
you need for that position a
receptionist at a hotel even more so i
think it's far better to focus on
improving your overall level in the
language acquiring more words doing more
listening and reading and not pretending
that just because you act out certain
roles or
certain tasks that that's going to
prepare you for that task you're better
off
to continue to improve your
comprehension through lots of listening
and reading and if you have that base
even if when you start in a particular
job you struggle if you have that
comprehension you have the vocabulary
you will eventually improve and it
really doesn't matter
you know
where you are theoretically in the sort
of steps of the 12 language benchmarks
what matters is how do we get to get the
person how do we encourage that person
how do we make it easier for that person
to continue to improve and get better
and better and i'm not sure that
the
sort of
canadian language benchmarks task based
instruction is the way to go on the
other hand assigning yourself tasks like
doing a lot of listening and reading and
speaking is probably going to get you
there sooner so maybe a little bit
controversial i'm sure i'll get some
pushback from professional language
teachers okay thanks for listening bye
for now